le loyer de ce département saigne à
blanc tous les mois ce chez vous tu
crois qu'on va tenir combien de temps
comme ça
ces quatre murs javier vers l'horizon
avec le poste que nous devons pour voir
c'est pour les débutants oui bon on
commence tous entendent y pense non
désolé je m'appelle travers
c'est ma
la première fois j'ai essayé essayé
d'arrêter ce que je raconte une femme
j'ai perdu ma fille
thomaes le secret c'est de savoir
anticiper connaître tes points faibles
quoi je vois ce énormément et il a dit
que je suis pas assez présent pour ma
fille et ses intérêts des points faibles
du coup
vous m'avez beaucoup aidé et maintenant
que j'ai un objectif
un projet auquel je vais me dédier à son
procès j'ai arrêté de me contenter de
regarder les autres profiter des choses
qu'ils savent même pas apprécié
leur marge se pose à dire c'est ça je t
invite à entendre
et à partir d'aujourd'hui je vais
attraper ma vie par les corps para du
montant couvre mois maintenant sans
demander la permission santé